well evil geniuses cs go roster is in
the news yet again and this time it
really is because of stewie or at least
it's about stewie
last week a former member of evil
geniuses cs go coaching staff did a
tell-all interview where he detailed how
certain antagonisms between he stu and
former head coach malik were essentially
the root cause of the roster's highly
publicized failure to perform it was
super spicy and all over social media
which drove stew to stream a steamy
tell-all of his own there's a lot to
break down so we're going to take you
through it step by step
alright so before we dive in
do the thing
like subscribe notifications
please also be sure to check out our
shiny new social series hot retakes
where i try my best to rtv inferno
whilst answering any and all burning
questions you might have for me who
knows maybe we'll even start live
streaming it
i emoji okay so if you've watched any of
the three or so don't at me's i've done
on evil geniuses new stewie helmed cs go
roster you know that they haven't been
doing very well the question on all of
our minds of course
is why the doors to the eg camp have
understandably been pretty closed as of
late in light of their abysmal results
save a few earnest apologetic tweets and
interviews there hasn't been a lot to go
on until now last week eg's former
assistant coach paolo evie berger budo
did an interview with french news outlet
in pve where he explained in spicy
scrutinizing detail just how rocky the
relationship was between stewie and the
malick-led coaching staff of which evie
was a part the gist of it is that from
the very first day of evie and malik's
arrival they were systematically shut
out by stewie's supposedly
cold-shouldered prima donna superstar
attitude evie characterized the american
roster as expecting coaches to be
so-called yes men and explained how he
and malik's strict carte blanche
infrastructure made them anything but
and that is when the anecdotes started
pouring out apparently it started with
stewie being a typical rank s rager who
refused to calm give his death cam and
as soon as evie and malik tried to
address that devolved into sue not only
refusing to acknowledge malek as he
entered the room but denying tactical
pauses the cherry on top had to be stew
outright refusing to call during pro
league even though eg's ceo nicole
lapointe jameson was standing right
beside the roster as they played the
general claim of course is that the
environment that stew created was so
hostile and unproductive and
unprofessional that neither malik nor
evie were able to implement the very
infrastructure they were brought in to
implement evie also alleges that by the
end of the rmr the other members of the
roster started wisening up to the fact
that stewie's attitude had become an
issue malik supposedly brought up his
issues with the team culture that stewie
was creating to management several times
and apparently nothing ever came of it
eventually maluk got so fed up that he
benched himself and he and evie were
both parted ways with shortly after now
that's evie's side of the story we
haven't heard malik's since he's opted
not to say anything about any of this
but evie's overall takeaway is that
stew's level of play is questionable he
doesn't challenge himself anymore and
he's not a good leader which i mean
i think is
a little bit extreme but i've also never
teamed with a guy what is undeniable and
what evie made a point of observing is
that the smoke criminal does in fact
have a .55
rating against top five teams whilst on
eg what is also difficult to deny is
that even if evie's account was somewhat
sensationalized as stewie has since gone
on to allege
it's still
pretty alarming to say the least stew
did of course respond to all of this
first by taking to twitter and calling
evie's account a twisted retelling from
someone he barely remembers having
antagonisms with and then by
subsequently turning on his twitch
stream and walking us through his side
of things
it became a little bit of a problem
because of the impatience
i feel like malik wanted to he wanted to
adopt the g2
system into
eg and i wanted to bring pieces of
liquid into eg as well and they are both
good they are both i'm sure that we can
put both pieces together but at the same
time this isn't g2 nor is it liquid i
don't have a liege i don't have naf we
don't have niko we don't have hunter
and i thought it was important to let
things flow in the beginning and let
things build naturally so we can see
people's natural instincts
and let all those things develop see
natural reactions how to play off each
other now stu's own stream was also like
an hour and a half so i can't summarize
everything that he talked about what i
can say is that he didn't so much deny
any of what evie alleged as much as he
just contextualized it basically and
then it just really made me feel like i
was being watched 24 7. like i had no
room to breathe like someone's bringing
down my neck and i'm being watched on my
every move and
kind of did feel that way like sometimes
i can really tell that eyes are on me
even though nothing's happening
but
yeah that's just how i felt in the
moment ultimately stewie did take
accountability for what he himself
admitted to be his own personal failings
for starters he addressed his own
performance on the server and that
pesky little 0.55 rating that everyone
was chiding him about the fact that he
even brought up my rating
don't you think that i'm aware i can
suck
that i'm putting
the team in front of me that i'm worried
about the other side of the map that i
have to make sure that we're making sure
what we're doing even the fact that
we're not ready and trying to focus on
everything else but my game
like yes it takes a toll and i'm not
blaming anyone for that like i don't
blame anyone for that i took
accountability for that even when the
moment happened after epl i tried
telling them that it was all my fault
like i sucked i don't know why i can't
kill anybody i don't know why i can't
put up numbers
like there's so much
there's so much more to take account for
like
like this just doesn't
really define
what happened to me like this season but
he did also address the issue of his
so-called toxic attitude like i
understand my attitude is not the best
i'm a guy who does not like to lose i
would win in any other condition i would
do anything to win
and anyone who's been watching me anyone
who's playing on my team knows that like
they know that
winning is everything to me
and
i do understand that my attitude does
get in the way and
at times when it's brought up like it
like i notice it i know i i have to work
on it and
even though it's been with me throughout
my entire career from the very beginning
when i joined cloud9
there are their moments of good and bad
it was also obvious to anyone watching
that stu was not only very emotional
about all of this but genuinely filled
with a sense of regret and remorse like
it's all me like this is all me this is
all me like all the [ __ ] on me and like
you don't think i know that like you
don't think i failed the project you
don't think i failed being a captain you
don't think i know any of that
like i like i failed the wrong approach
i failed everything i want to turn back
time and fix it the right way i want to
do all of that but i can't
and i'm sorry for all the fans that had
to see our results this year
we couldn't win a map we couldn't do any
of that suffice it to say stewie has
never
really been everyone's cup of tea that's
not to say that any of his ostensibly
inexcusable behavior is
well
excusable simply that he does have a
style and personality that's very easy
to denigrate when it isn't racking up
trophies
and need i remind you that it has racked
up a fair number of trophies that said
all signs point to a breaking point of
sorts there's pretty much no way in
which the boy does not emerge from this
looking like the bad guy and he knows
that and has owned up to it the question
is
where does young stu go from here do eg
give him another crack in the captain's
chair do they try putting someone else
in as the igl
or
do they get rid of him entirely his rock
bottom tweet from two months ago seemed
to indicate that he was not ready to
give up cs
but who knows a lot's changed since then
there's also that recently leaked dm
convo with wardell to consider since
there seemed to be an indication that
stu could be entertaining a switch to
valorant either as a streamer a
competitor or both it is sort of the
only move away from eg that makes sense
since
well it
it's kind of the only move available if
eg really ends up not working out for
stu
i don't really think there's anywhere
else for him to go at least not
domestically reputational blows aside he
just came from liquid and i can't really
see complexity disrupting their rebuild
by throwing stew into the mix and aside
from those two there aren't really any
other north american rosters who are
both rebuilding and looking to house a
player of his caliber so until something
concrete comes along we'll just have to
cross our fingers
and hope for the best not just for stu
and for eg but
nacs at large
honestly i don't even know how to end
board this like i don't it sort of feels
weird to have an end board for a video
like this it's just so sad
like
maybe that's the end board i don't know
all right i just maybe that's the end
board it's just i think i think we're
literally in the m4 i think we're in the
end board high-end board
high-end board